-Performing "Sexy After Dark"
from his album,
"See You Next Time,"
here's Joshua Ray Walker.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ I feel sexy after dark ♪
♪ My conscience finds it
hard to see ♪
♪ I'll share pieces of
my heart ♪
♪ Fewer words make me sound
so smart ♪
♪ I'll let 'em slip out
slowly ♪
♪ Trading glances, clinking
glasses till we part ♪
♪ I feel sexy after dark ♪
♪♪
♪ You say ♪
♪ That you're always
gonna get your way ♪
♪ I play games ♪
♪ Whoo-hoo-hoo ♪
♪♪
♪ I feel sexy after dark ♪
♪ Be any me I wanna be ♪
♪ Anticipation is a lost art ♪
♪ Saw it coming
from the very start ♪
♪ You say you want a go,
my vision dances ♪
♪ Locked in trances,
feel that spark ♪
♪ I feel sexy after dark ♪
♪♪
♪ You say that you're always
gonna get your way ♪
♪ I play games ♪
♪ Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo ♪
♪♪
♪ Whoo! ♪
Come on.
♪♪
♪ I feel sexy after dark ♪
♪ My conscience finds it hard
to see ♪
♪ I share pieces of my heart ♪
♪ Fewer words make me sound
so smart ♪
♪ I feel sexy after... ♪
♪♪
♪ Dark ♪